The story of Despicable Me 3 was a much tougher
nut to crack for its screenwriters than the
first two films in the franchise, which means
that there are a number of scenes that wound
up being deleted and several concepts that
ended up rejected from the final version of
Illuminations' latest animated movie!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to reveal and
explain some of the scenes and ideas that
were cut from the theatrical release of Despicable
Me 3.
I've also got several sets of awesome merchandise
from the movie to give away.
For a chance to win, make sure you subscribe
and turn on your notifications, and answer
the question I'll be asking later in the video!
A quick reminder: there are some spoilers
in this video, so take care if you haven't
seen the movie yet.
Despicable Me 3 screenwriters Cinco Paul and
Ken Daurio have said they had trouble finding
the right role for Lucy in this movie.
Indeed, in early drafts of the script, Lucy's
role was going to be very different to what
we see in the final movie.
Originally, once Gru and his family arrived
in Freedonia, Lucy was going to start fighting
crime there.
Actually, if you think about it, this storyline
would have fit in rather nicely with how Lucy's
character was first established in Despicable
Me 2 where she was an undercover agent for
the Anti-Villain League and obviously enjoyed
her job fighting crime, so it makes sense
she would miss that part of her life when
she and Gru are fired from the AVL in this
movie.
And given the way Lucy used various gadgets
including a tranquilizer gun and lipstick
taser in the second film, I can't help but
wonder what new gadgets she would have used
in her crime-fighting in Despicable Me 3 if
the filmmakers had gone ahead with that storyline.
What we do know though is that during the
movie's Cheese Festival in Freedonia, there
was a big scene cut which would have featured
Lucy chasing after a robber who'd stolen an
old woman's purse.
As you can imagine from the kind of humour
we see in the Despicable Me movies, this deleted
scene was full of slapstick moments as well
as cheese-based puns and sight gags.
For instance, Lucy was going to have to dodge
a whole load of statues made of cheese and
other cheesey stuff as she raced after the
purse-snatcher, and when she finally caught
him she was going to tell him that 'This is
nacho day!'
In the end though, the screenwriters decided
Lucy's vigilante storyline was too disconnected
from the rest of the movie and they wanted
her story to have more of an emotional pay-off
this time, so they focused their attention
on building up Lucy's relationship with Margot,
Edith, and Agnes, and how she deals with becoming
their step-mum.
In fact, that decision meant that Lucy's storyline
in this film took a similar path to Gru's
in the first Despicable Me movie, as both
Lucy and Gru face challenges becoming a parent
to the girls, but end up becoming close to
them and later save their lives after they're
kidnapped by the movie's villain.
Despite all that, I think I still would have
preferred the more active and action-packed
crime-fighting storyline for Lucy in this
movie.
Although former child star Balthazar Bratt
is very clearly the new big bad who Team Gru
has to defeat in Despicable Me 3, the filmmakers
didn't always have Bratt in mind to be their
new movie's number one villain.
You see, one of the first ideas for the movie
was that Bratt was just a henchman to another
big supervillain who was the main focus of
the film.
However, that original supervillain was pretty
humourless, and just didn't work for the movie
because, as Despicable Me 3 producer Chris
Meledandri has said, 'you need to give Gru
a worthy adversary – someone who presents
a real challenge [….], as well as someone
who is worthy comedically.
Gru is so fun and lively, that if you put
a very straight villain against him, that
character will just disappear.'
Fortunately, when the filmmakers saw the animators'
early sketches of Balthazar Bratt, they realised
that his character had a lot more potential
than they first thought and that he was actually
the 'worthy adversary for Gru' that they'd
been looking for.
So, they upgraded Bratt's role from a mere
side-kick to a 1980s-obsessed supervillain
out to destroy Hollywood.
Speaking of Balthazar Bratt's fixation with
all things 1980s, of course, that means the
movie contains a ton of pop culture references
to fashion, TV shows, movies, and music from
that decade.
But not everything the screenwriters had in
mind to show off Bratt's 80s mania made it
into the final cut of the film.
For example, Trey Parker, who provides the
voice of Balthazar Bratt and is best known
as co-creator and star of South Park, recorded
a bunch of songs for use in the movie including
Karma Chameleon, a classic song from 1983
by the British band Culture Club.
However, those songs ended up on the cutting
room floor when the scene where Bratt was
going to sing a track from the 1980s was completely
dropped from the movie.
However, we do still get to hear voice actor
Trey Parker sing in the movie, but now it's
a new track called Hug Me which was written
by Pharrell Williams.
By the way, I've made a separate video about
all the cool easter eggs and movie references
in Despicable Me 3, and there's a link to
that in the video description below and at
the end of this video.
Long-lost twin brothers Gru and Dru are opposites
in many ways and their contrasting personalities
influenced the filmmakers' design of Dru.
In fact, Dru's look in the final film, including
his flowing blond hair and white suit versus
Gru's bald head and dark clothes, was one
of co-director Eric Guillon's first designs
for Dru.
However, before the filmmakers finally decided
on that particular look for Gru's new brother,
they tried out a variety of other looks, including
having Dru wear a big fur coat over a sweat
shirt, a design which emphasised that Dru
was both very laid-back and very wealthy thanks
to having inherited his father's enormous
fortune and pig farm.
In the end though, that look was rejected
in favour of their first design which the
filmmakers felt reflected Dru's personality
in a much simpler and clearer way.
The clear-cut differences between the newly-reunited
twin brothers are played up during a family
dinner scene, which was also the subject of
several cuts.
This scene where Gru and Dru swap clothes
and hairstyles, and generally clown around
pretending to be each other, started out quite
a bit longer than the scene we see in the
final film, with the brothers' back-and-forth
banter initially stretching out to over 3
minutes.
The scene was actually rather complicated
as Steve Carell, who voices Gru and Dru, had
to play each character imitating the other
character in a conversation between themselves!
So, to make it easier, Carell recorded all
Gru's lines first, then went back and recorded
all Dru's lines later.
There's also another funny moment that takes
place at Dru's mansion in Freedonia which
was cut from the final movie.
In the deleted scene, Gru and Dru are wearing
their new spy costumes and are examining one
of Dru's many weapons when, suddenly, Lucy
walks in on them and is pretty annoyed as
she thinks they're now both going to be villains!
"So, you two are villains now?!"
"Whaaaaaa ha ha ha ... I mean hello sweetie"
"Uh oh, busted!"
Although this scene ended up being deleted,
it looks like there's still a little trace
of what the filmmakers were going for with
this moment in the final film.
Just after Lucy sends away Niko's mother for
cursing Margo, she walks towards the window
in Dru's mansion and spots Gru and Dru in
their spy costumes jetting off in their speedboat.
Lucy looks pretty annoyed, like she knows
something is going on and thinks the brothers
are up to no-good, which likely relates back
to that deleted scene where she discovered
Gru and Dru in their lair.
Now, what do you think about the deleted scenes
and rejected concepts?
And would you like to have seen any of them
in the movie?
I'd love to hear your thoughts in the comments
below.
For a chance to win this awesome Despicable
Me 3 merchandise, be sure to subscribe, and
leave a comment about the movie, and also
answer the following question:
What was the name of the song Balthazar Bratt
was going to sing that got cut from the movie?
Make sure you turn on your notifications to
get all my new videos where I'll be announcing
the winners of the giveaway.
And let me know what movie deleted scenes
you'd like me to do in a future video.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate you
hitting that thumbs-up button and check out
some more of my deleted scenes and animation
videos right here.
Congratulations to the first winner of my
Cars 3 giveaway who is on the screen now!
If that's you, send me a message on YouTube
or via my email on my About page so I can
get your details to send you the prize.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!